[? Sermon ?] just
gave you some rules.
But if there are
rules, then there
are exceptions to those rules.
As you're very well
aware of, we're
allowed to include stylesheets,
images, videos, IFrames,
and even scripts
from other origins
as well as send form
data to other origins.
The end user won't
be able to tell
that one image is
loaded from our server
while another is
loaded from Instagram.
However, for web developers,
there is a difference.
You can't interact
with an image tag that
is showing a cross origin
image in the same way you
could with an image
from the same origin.
For example, you can't inspect
the pixels of the image
from inside the Canvas element.
The same goes for a script tag
that includes a cross origin
script resource.
The contents will either
just silently appear empty.
Or in case of more
modern APIs, it
will explicitly throw an error.
For the same origins script tag,
I have access to its contents
but I can't access the other
origin scripts contents.
It's important to keep in mind
that the user's browser is
the one who enforces
the same origin policy.
It's not the server but
the client that will not
let you send off requests.
We'll see why this is important
as we look into getting around
same origin policy
restrictions in the next video.